people of the internet's retro Records
who are here and this is the brand new
obscurus card and trust me guys it
absolutely slaps in PvP I finally got
one it took me a while but we're gonna
take a look at two matches today the
first match you're gonna see some pretty
good uses of the card the second match
you're gonna see some things that I
never even expected that this card would
be able to do especially if you're a
Bellatrix user I am loving this card so
far it took me a while to get it a lot
of red keys but finally got it running
my Bellatrix Echo right now which if you
guys are Bellatrix players
obscurus is gonna be very nice for you
too it's gonna be very nice because you
see how my meter right there for the
Death Eater was going up with
atmospheric charm well just wait a
second here when we actually use it
actually use obscurus so this fight
starting off you know pretty even so far
they've got a little bit of an advantage
right now that was a great confringo
they used early on
I kind of wasted that explosive because
I think Hermione was walking in there
anyway they are running a Hermione Echo
and of course I'm running belatrix here
so we get the Pixies going with the bomb
box they throw a thunderstorm
unfortunately it took me a bit I finally
got nebulous by this point I decide
let's go ahead and use it anyway
just so I can recover a little bit of
Health right there maybe not the best
use of nebulas
and then you see I've got obscurus ready
I'm just waiting for the right moment to
use it now I've been experimenting with
using it against mobs and also using it
against just one or two so watch this
they go in nebulous
mcgonagall's in there too
and I've got five right now I throw
obscurus
so it almost takes care of McGonagall
but does some pretty solid damage
against them and also helps to build up
my Death Eater meter
so now I can throw Ron we can throw the
Death Eater we got Pixies we got bomb
box and the comeback begins
got the cats going in there as well this
time I've got nebulous right at the
beginning of thunderstorm so I'm gonna
go ahead and throw it
because I know they're probably not
going to be able to force me out of
nebulous because I'm just
sending away right right there look at
that obscurus just when they get inside
the nebulous
so basically it completely negates their
nebulous right there and also does quite
a bit of damage now the downside of
obscurus you guys might notice the red
damage numbers that appear
whenever they hit me immediately after
so that is the biggest counter to this
card right now
is if you can hit them
within five seconds of them okay so see
look at my character right here see the
little red
that means that I am more susceptible 40
more
on damage for the next five seconds so
anytime somebody uses obscurus against
you if you can get a lot of damage on
them very quick after that
then it's gonna be a great move for you
all right so now we're just sitting in
Hagrid and the comeback is just about
complete we've got atmospheric charm
going they go in nebulous and then look
to finish off the fight right there okay
now in this fight right here is where
you're gonna see two ass absolutely
insane uses for this card that I did not
think about so remember how I said I was
trying to decide whether it's good for
mobs whether it's good for just one
person the reason at first I thought it
might be good for mobs which it can be
but I don't think it hits every single
person inside the range an equal number
of times so the way the card works is
it's just a series of basic attacks and
very rapid succession I think it's like
four or five we'll check the card here
in a second and then it ends with sort
of this explosion at the end which does
the big damage so you want them to be in
for the end of that and also if you're
on the other side of it you want to get
out of that
so keep that in mind that I said I've
been experimenting with Mobs so there
you see our first use of obscurus right
there
and look at that you can use it to
deliver a Death Eater
we ran a tournament last night in our
live stream and someone described it to
me as being sort of similar to
broomstick which I hadn't thought about
because you're actually turning into the
obscurus
so because I was over there and I used
it just when my Death Eater was about to
arrive it also transports the Death
Eater didn't do a ton of damage but it
did a little bit and it's gonna catch
the opponent off guard just think about
if you're ready for two Death Eaters if
you're ready for three Death Eaters and
you're able to time that just right
where you use the obscurus now notice
this person is also running Bellatrix
and we just got a really big Advantage
right now here comes Ron
I'm getting hit by the Death Eater not
much I can do so here we go obscurus
coming up right
now
and it just about finishes offer on and
also took care of the Pixies
so I don't think it's going to be good
for a lot of mobs but if they're all
kind of weak I think it'll be able to
finish them off peer totem locomotor
that one I I don't have any video of
that one but I did use it a couple times
and it does good damage but keep in mind
most people's pure totem locomotor cards
are already upgraded whereas mine is
just the obscurus is only a level nine
right here
hopefully I can get more of them to
upgrade it but all right we're almost to
the point of the next insane use of
obscurus
see the Death Eater just getting big
time damage right there
all right so it looks like they're
almost dead right looks like it's over
no
no they bring out Haggard they get
thunderstorm going I go in nebulous and
then they're gonna call in
hold on wait for it antipody and opal
eye look at that it's almost at full
health obscurus
just instantly takes out the opal eye
and again mine is just a level nine and
then we go on and get the victory now
another big question I had about this
card is how exactly will it play with
the Snape Echo and you can see here that
it does slightly more damage but not as
much as I thought it would now if you go
into the description which I always
encourage players to do because there's
almost always going to be some sort of
little nugget of information here that's
going to be helpful that maybe you
didn't know before like this right here
Invincible obscurus this is very
important transforms you into an
invincible obscurus and then here's what
it's actually going to do it's going to
launch six rapid basic attacks on random
enemy units in the Target area while
briefly slowing them so if you use it on
a bunch of mobs it is not going to do
the damage equally it is spread out
randomly between them so if there's a
lot of mobs you probably don't want to
use it two to three maybe they're kind
of low Health then it might be a really
good time to use it after the attacks
though the target Zone explodes dealing
massive damage to all enemy units inside
and erasing the obscura status so you're
no longer Invincible at that point you
then return to your starting point so
you can be in all different areas of the
map and use this card to kind of jump
around anywhere and then it's going to
take you right back where you were
where's the downside right there's got
to be some disadvantage to this card
here it is if there are no opponent
units in the Target area the area will
be detonated and the attack will end
when the obscurus effect wears off you
are weakened and take 40 percent more
damage for five seconds so you have to
be very careful here you don't
necessarily want to use this when you
know they have a lot of MP built up if
they were able to throw something like
inflatus and whiz bang right after this
that is just incredible incredible
damage if you want to know more about
that card I already have a video about
how this deck with Hermione is so
incredibly op it's over on the right
side of your screen now so check that
one out next guys as always thank you
all so much for watching I'll talk to
you again soon